dust off your soul Reaper robes and
sharpen your zompoc toe because the
long-awaited return of bleach
Thousand-Year blood War Arc part 2 is on
the horizon ichigo's brand new weapon
dominated the bleach epilogue will this
weapon allow each go to release his full
potential as he continues to train with
Squad zero the part one finale featured
Ichigo Kurosaki learning about his
family history we also saw the first
encounter between each goes Quincy
mother and soul Reaper Father which was
so good to see in the special episode it
was also revealed how uru made the
decision to fight alongside Quincy's
after meeting yuha and yugram the Quincy
threat looms large and the fate of the
Soul Society hangs in the balance will
our heroes emerge Victorious or will
Darkness Prevail find out in the return
of bleach Thousand-Year blood War Arc
part 2. don't forget to hit that like
button and subscribe to our channel for
more exciting updates get ready because
the world of bleach is about to ignite